hey it's evan i am in sunny Orlando I
just got here from Toronto flew here and
i'm filling a pilot show for a new show
that I'm working on so that's exciting
and the best part of the trip so far I
was able to wear five toe shoes through
security because they said they look
like socks and they weren't officially
shoes so at the airport I didn't have to
take these things off which is amazing
because it can be a bit of a pain to put
on them out so I'm here in Orlando this
is the place that I got and that this is
an Airbnb place I've never done anything
on Airbnb before this is my first shot
it's a pretty funky-looking place is
just outside Disney World I'm doing part
of the show is going to be on Walt
Disney so we're going to Disney wealth
of film part of it and so I got this
place I thought I gotta try out Airbnb
and we'll see what looks like so you're
going to join me on my first tour as I
go inside our place we are this is
looking pretty good there's Nina there's
Hayden hi guys we got a pretty spacious
living room here nice TV dining room
kitchen this is a pretty sweet place
what else we got too bad so what buddy
of mine Louise also bringing up his his
son Skyler and we're going to be here so
the kids are going to share a room we
get a room and then I guess Louie gets a
room we got here first so we get to pick
the best room Sarah doing what's in here
Oh bathroom okay and another bathroom in
here that's a pretty good place when we
were looking at places we're trying to
decide should we try air B&B or should
we get a typical hotel like we don't
normally do and thought you know why I
gotta give this Airbnb thing a shot and
i'm pretty happy with it so far i'll
keep you guys updated i'll take you
along my journey kind of behind the
scenes of what I'm doing to film this
pilot show we'll see what happens and
I'm hoping for a good one
so it's nighttime here first night we
are we ate dinner but I was still
peckish I was hungry so I went out I got
a mcflurry I also went to walgreens and
and only in America can you find this
this is great only in America the brand
new chips i was gonna get sour cream and
onion but instead the brand new flavor
is chicken and waffles it sounded so
disgusting that I had to try so Louise
gonna open it up we're gonna try the
this is smell like chicken walk you know
I actually don't know what chicken a la
Madame it just sounds gross it sounds it
sounds gross is trying this track this
is the first chicken and waffle hmm okay
no net you try some chicken it's like
barbecue oh it tastes like bacon is a
little bit at waffle anyway I'm off I
have to have my awesome mcflurry Oreo
with caramel bits will try some more of
those trips later these are the exciting
things that you learn watching my
youtube channel anyway we'll report back
tomorrow off to disney for the first day
and we'll see you soon okay we're at
Disney World and we're going on it's a
small world
that we'll see how it goes I'm sure
we'll all be singing a song once we get
a
in the slime
stay free we're at epcot center we have
to build our own car so I've got to put
my card here it's a fun test drive thing
you don't right that's my losing us look
at that bad boy yes
we're getting in line here at test track
we're going to put our cards in the zoo
drive safe okay
and here we are
I'm cracking up Anita's hairs all over
the place a guy next to me a few people
behind this I don't know but that was a
lot of fun we're coming up on Louie
who's been waiting with the kids you
were having a holla how you guys doing
you're lucky they burned all their
energy running around okay okay we're
going to continue on your name for here
we're at something animal kingdom about
to go on a gentleman jarrow try to see
some animals
you
we just got off the rapids it says
whitewater rapids thing and we got
soaked let's see can you see my wet
pants but Nina got the worst of it Nina
got the worst of it got all in her hair
and soaked there you go Nina got all wet
okay and she gets to stay dry by putting
on her new yeah that's true by put it on
my sweatshirt Louie has been babysitting
and the boys are running around we're
off to see some more animals we'll see
what happens so it's been a pretty full
day here and watching them I'm sending
the burnout get a headache it's kind of
overcast weather is having an impact on
me but I wish I could be this guy right
here
I want to be Hayden in my car seat or my
stroller passing at wat tour I'm Amy a
production coordinator here at the
studio it's made by yourself tornadoes
permission to come in and look around
I'm on here with our necks crew we're
getting ready to shoot a test sequence
so I've enrolled Peyton in a Jedi Knight
school where they teach you how to
become a Jedi Knight and it's always
been talking about all day so Hayden
before we go to school go in there next
can you show us can you show us how you
use your light saber sword
go to school and see how you do
so it's day six here in Orlando and I am
super sick you can probably tell him my
voice right now it sound like I
swallowed a frog went to disney for a
couple hours I just had nor need you to
film anything we're supposed to do stuff
for my secret project but just couldn't
and we'll see anyway I'm loading up on
advil I'm here for another day tomorrow
I'm supposed to go drive to dunedin to
go watch the Blue Jays the main reason
for tagging the sign was to go to the
spring training game I love the Blue
Jays and watching how they play so we'll
see hopefully I feel better I'm trying
to record some video so everybody I know
I owe everybody a ton of videos lots of
questions came in and I was supposed to
spot some time tomorrow to record
hopefully I can if I'm not hopefully you
guys don't don't tell hate on me too
much but I'm hoping for a good rest
tonight and I'll check in again tomorrow
I just arrived at dunedin we drove
almost two hours from Orlando didn't
even because I want to check out the
Blue Jays so we're here at dunedin
stadium you can tell i'm still super
sick the game was just about to get
started though is crazy traffic to get
here so uh anyway we're a little bit
late you can hear that crowd she's
starting check out the parking spot the
guy gave me this is where I'm parking
can barely get out I think that guy is
gonna smash from the way in hopefully
the Jays win Go juice go enough like
make it through this game so this is
done even stadium i love how small and
intimate it is and here is was a
teesta that's blue tape player look at
the stadium it's pretty tiny so it's a
really close intimate filled with the
crowd so the Blue Jays 1 10 to six we
started off way behind and caught up
with a eight run inning which is great
news it means the Blue Jays are going to
win the World Series this year that
that's what I mean so we're going to
drive home we found a salsa radio
station that we're going to listen to
hopefully we get it all the way back
almost two hour drive back home and then
I'm gonna need a nap because I'm pretty
burnt out and still very sick we'll see
you soon okay so it's my last day I was
supposed to be back home already in
Toronto but my connecting flight in
Philadelphia got canceled got canceled i
SAT there on the plane for about an hour
they weren't sure what was wrong and
they got canceled so I am up at a
sheraton near the hotel still sick
here's it what yeah yeah you want to say
something Hayden is up way past his
bedtime here is my new hotel room take
you on a grand tour I have to be up and
out of here my flight is at seven
something in the morning so that means I
gotta be up in that by what I got to
wake up five something so typical
bathroom anyway this is becoming the big
saga the big sigh got to get home but
hopefully our flight tomorrow is all ok
I'll be back in Toronto I'm missing
toronto now I'm homesick I want to be
home we got these combo packs open up a
chocolate pocket ixia what they gave us
so yours Airways sucky US airways I hate
US airways crappy service standing in
line to to customer service people to
handle like a hundred people on the
plane what did they give us here
toothpaste what else huh what is that
hair comb comb yeah what are you holding
what is that answers oh this is the fish
washed face wash that's a shampoo
whatever shampoo and conditionally okay
yeah this is to a facial cleansing power
and shaped kids if you need to you I do
need to shave do I need to shave what do
you think people I need to shave yeah I
need to shave and our breakfast tomorrow
is gonna be a mix of honey-roasted
peanuts yummy if you liked the honey
roasted peanuts combined with
chocolate-covered almonds all right
there's a healthy breakfast you can't
yeah well you're gonna have to wait till
tomorrow mr. ok it's past your bedtime
oh oh you found some let's put those
away okay well thank you for saving
those okay so we're gonna get you to bed
I'm gonna pop a night quo I've been
popular every six hours are moved over
from at from advil tonight well because
the advil is just for fever or where I
need something a little more intense so
that's it for now we're off can I have a
good sleep everybody hopefully tomorrow
back in toronto and i'm back to feeling
good so we just made it back it is 1030
on friday morning its day what day is it
nein nein nein it's good to be back I
have the day off to kind of recover I
think we need we need to we need the
weekend to have a vacation from the
vacation settle back my bag has been the
biggest casualty of this trip check out
my bag got this crazy this was from
carrying the tripod around the bag so
this one has to go and I got some I
don't know what that is I think that's
tomato juice from the flight I don't
know that's nasty just gross stuff on
the bag so i think i think i'm going to
give my back to neenah now Nina needs a
new backpack here right you get this
back right so it's a shower time relax
time weekend vacation time thanks for
joining us on this trip and we'll see
you soon
you